[Music]
apple recently announced its new ipad
mini
and people are wondering if a smaller
ipad
is really necessary well here's apple's
latest ad and you should judge for
yourself we at apple are thrilled with
the ipad mini
we put everything you love about the
ipad in a smaller package but then we
thought
what if we combine the sleekness of the
ipad mini with the rich display of the
original ipad introducing the ipad mini
mega
at 8.8 inches it's the perfect blend of
the ipad and the ipad mini but then we
had a new idea what if we put everything
you love about the ipad mini mega in a
smaller package introducing the ipad
mini mega micro at 8.4 inches it's a
revolutionary mix of other revolutionary
things but then we thought what if we
jammed another size in there introducing
the ipad mini mega micro max
at 8.8 inches it's actually the same
size as the first one
whoops
the ipad family is a rich array of
barely different options and let's not
forget the ipad monstro
at over 100 inches it barely fits in a
door
[Music]
we're drunk with power
i must
i must buy all of them